you had incredible success
at snl and
um with all of your different characters
and
what's interesting and i know you've
this has
got to be a powerful theme for you
but i want to just go back to your
childhood because it's so defining when
you were ill you were seriously
seriously ill yeah and i believe you had
leukemia
yeah yeah and you'd think that that
would um
not fuel comedy right right but even at
the time that you were sick as a child
yeah your family tried to find humor in
it is that right yes we would joke about
it all the time and we would
particularly joke about all the like
perks we got from it and
we would like use it like what perks
well wow free chemo
[Laughter]
try and get that at a party
she said well there's
no i'm sorry no no no no i i it's just
like it's like whenever you go through a
difficult time
people are so nice to you yeah you know
yeah so maybe i'm messed up that i focus
on that but like i like i was in high
school and i could like come into school
late all the time like i just came into
school
whenever i wanted we had such a strict
attendance woman and a lot of times it
was because you know i wanted to sleep
in especially like when you know later
on in my treatment when things were like
you know i was starting to feel better
and stuff i just could like come in
whenever i wanted i didn't have to do
gym class
oh my god wow that's that is you guys
aren't reacting
no no but i that one hit me no no trust
me you were talking to three people who
are very happy to miss gym class yeah
right yeah i mean what is more
humiliating in high school than gym
class you have to change into the outfit
and it's so and they want you to climb
up a rope
and your arms don't work this is what i
remember yeah i couldn't climb up that
rope yeah i just was like i i don't want
to start doing this and they were like
okay
um
what else like i didn't have to someone
asked me to homecoming and i said well i
ha sorry i have chemo that weekend was
this someone you didn't want to go it
was someone i didn't want to go with
okay and then i actually ended up going
with someone else
but oh my god oh my god how did
that person feel
i can't make it i've got change the
weekend
of my chemo but i'm still not going to
make you a good person having cancer
doesn't make you a kid
hey if we can get one moral out of
today's episode
then yeah yeah okay so there's no upside
to cancer then this is what i'm hearing
okay i'd like to think i mostly didn't
use it for stuff like that but
either way
[Laughter]
i also always really like detention yes
and it's a great way to get it it's like
it's like when you're a kid and you see
like someone come on the bus and they
have a broken leg and you're like well
it must be nice to be then
you know like everyone's gonna sign
their cast now okay i have i
can exactly i can exactly relate to what
you're talking about because when i was
when i was in the was i was in the
fourth grade
when i was in the fourth grade um
as anyone who knows anything about me
knows i'm one of six and we were born
you know weeks apart and
um jammed in together and i was kind of
in the middle and i felt very anonymous
and uh and really was thinking how do i
get attention it was nice to get some
attention
one day in the fourth grade it was in
december i remember was right near my
brother's birthday i went to school and
we had gym class and that day was
wrestling and as a joke
someone came running up and jumped on me
and i fell backwards to put my arm back
and it bent the wrong way and i really
broke my elbow badly they were like well
you're going to the nurse and i go to
the nurse and my arm won't work and i
know something's wrong
and they call my mom and my mom comes
rushing to school i'm like my mom
is coming to school she loves me yeah
she loves me
[Laughter]
and there i can remember the nurse on
the phone saying it's conan no he's no
not luke
no no no that's neil you're thinking of
no no it's not justin no kate is a girl
no it's not no it's not jane either no
it's okay and she was like got it got it
but she came they take me to the
hospital
they uh gave me a drug that made me
super high i remembered
like i don't know what this is but
i suddenly have no inhibitions
and then they put me in a big cast my
mom took me home
they put me like on a couch in like the
center of the house
and i remembered all my brothers and
sisters coming home and coming up to me
to see how i was and everybody talking
about me and i was told you don't have
to go to school
and it's almost christmas vacation
anyway so you're going to have multiple
weeks off from school
and then i remembered my mom because it
was before christmas she went and got
one of the toys that quote santa was
going to give me and gave it to me ahead
of time
and i was sitting there thinking this is
[ __ ] awesome yeah
and then walking around with a big cast
and a girl i had a crush on being like
are you okay and i'm like well i don't
know
i may lose the arm
ah
[Music]
so i mean and that's just a broken arm
that's not leukemia that's not cancer
yeah but i understand there is a weird
um
i don't know power that can come from it
totally totally and
you know obviously that was like
i feel like
sort of focusing on that stuff helped me
get through that time but we really had
fun with it